>>Paul Irish: Hi, everyone.
Hello.
My name is Paul Irish and we're going to dive
into the Chrome DevTools.
Since Google I/O last year there's been a
lot of work put into DevTools.
I'm going to show just a little bit of some
of the features that have landed.
So the way that we're going to go into this,
we're going to dive into some of the improvements
made to authoring, just building out and working
with the tools to iterate on your -- your
application, your site; dive into what that
looks like on mobile; and then dive into some
of the ground-breaking performance features
that really change how you can get insight
and understand how to fix performance situations
with your app.
All right.
So first stop, I want to play a little bit
of this video.
This is Remy Sharp, and a bit ago he made
a short video on kind of how he never even
leaves the DevTools when he does development.
>>> So what I'm going to do here is just make
a feature and just hopefully you already know
about this and you can just kind of stick
your mouse cursor straight in and we can just
go to blue and if I hit "command S" --
>>Paul Irish: So what he's showing here is
actually two separate things.
One is that he has live edit in the JavaScript.
Any changes he's making in the JavaScript
are immediately patched up to V8 and it starts
evaluating the new code.
And the second feature, separately, is he's
making these changes back to disk and saving
them so that they persist to disk.
We like this.
We think this is really powerful and if you've
seen the Brent Victor talk, having a -- an
environment where you can iterate live against
your production application that you're building
really changes the whole development lifecycle.
So today, I'm going to share with you something
called "workspaces."
Actually, I have a problem with this slide.
First of all, there's a capital "O." Okay.
One second.
I'm just going to fix this.
Okay.
Let's see.
We're going to go down here and then actually
the styling is not totally keen -- I'm not
-- we could make this better, I think.
I'm going to add some text shadow, probably.
Let's give it some of this.
Yeah, it's like a little glow.
I like that.
Wow!
Maybe change up the color.
Let's see.
I'll just make it a little bit lighter.
And bump the font size.
Ooh.
Line height.
Sheesh.
Okay, okay, okay.
1.1 sounds about good.
Yeah.
All right.
So I've made these changes.
I should probably, you know, copy them.
Or maybe I'll go over here and I could copy
them over from here, go back to sublime and
see we're in my default CSS.
Section, line height.
Wait.
Um... okay, I -- let's see if I can get this
on screen at the same time here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sure.
So, uh, line height and colors.
Brighten that up.
And let's see.
Ahh.
Then I have a little bit of box shadow.
10px, black, seems good.
Come down here, and what you're seeing, actually
-- so all my changes that I'm making in styling
--
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: All my changes that I'm making
here in the style panel are persistent to
disk and I immediately have them over here.
Now, I can make my edits here or I can come
over here and actually just kill this box
shadow and, you know, tweak my line height.
But I have the editability in both places.
I can also come back, say, for instance, to
-- to sublime.
Maybe I'm going to make my change down here,
so instead -- I'm going to kill the box shadow
down here and we'll change the color over
to indigo.
That one's been -- I like that style.
Come back, and immediately my change comes
up in the DevTools.
No refresh.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: So I'm really keen on this,
and I think it's really powerful, but it's
backed up by a bit of -- a bit of work.
So --
Ah.
One last thing.
The capitalization that I didn't even get
to.
So let's take a look at that.
So these are HTML styles -- HTML slides, but
I'm using markdown to actually generate them,
so if I want to change this, I should probably
edit my markdowns.
So what I'm going to do is just hit command
"O" inside here, bring up my slides for markdown,
and inside here -- so this is just my markdown
source.
I'm going to change the capitalization, hit
"save," hit "refresh," and we got my changes
in place here.
So this is really powerful and we're really
excited about what we can do here.
Workspaces allows you to map what's coming
into the browser to the local filesystem,
so in this case, I have -- this is the workspace
for my slides.
I have the entire local filesystem and that's
been mapped by DevTools to what's coming in
the browser.
So I can edit my JavaScript, my CSS, my HTML,
my markdown files.
Even the DevTools engineering team who is
building this edits their -- their C++ bindings
directly inside the DevTools.
The style changes that I'm making inside the
style pane persist.
I can edit.
The changes are kept.
I can undo, redo any of the changes in here,
which is just command "Z," command shift "Z,"
and this is great because I'm able to maintain
my context for styling.
So I don't have to be bopping in and out of
a different editor to make these changes.
I can make them all here in one place.
All right.
So this is looking pretty good.
I'm going to move on.
Last year at I/O, we asked everyone what features
you wanted inside of DevTools, and one of
the top things that people wanted was support
for Sass.
Because you're editing in Sass, you're authoring
there, but then in the DevTools you're seeing
CSS and you kind of need to manually map back
and forth.
So this is something that we've been working
on, and I wanted to show you how this works.
So I'm going to bring up a little copy of
HTML5 Please.
This is a site with a small node back end
but the styles are written in Sass, and we
want to take a look at how that works.
So let's take this little views badge right
here.
Now normally, if I am looking at the styling,
I'm going to see something like this, right?
So we got the green box shadow, border right,
and background.
We're all using this green, and in fact, it's
using just a little bit darker as it goes
down.
Now, I can click over to see my CSS, but as
I said, this is compiled, so -- from my Sass,
so it's not very helpful.
So let's turn on Sass debugging.
So when I go into DevTool settings -- I like
using the question mark for this, a quick
little shortcut -- go into experiments, turn
on Sass debugging, and now I'm just going
to refresh the page so that this is all looking
good.
And now the first difference that you're going
to see is that right here we're listing the
original place inside the Sass file where
this was -- where this was found.
So I can click over to that and we're looking
inside my Sass file where this -- where this
selector was found.
So we got my use, and it looks like we're
applying a mix-in inside here.
Okay.
Cool.
But actually I want to change this green,
so I'm going to have to do a little bit more
hunting.
So as I hold down the command key, I actually
get a little bit of visual feedback.
As I hover, I get these little underlines,
so I'm going to try clicking "background."
We're going to jump immediately into where
that mix-in was defined.
I can see my background, my box shadow, my
border right.
All right.
But yeah, we got this color.
It comes in.
It's getting darkened and I want to edit the
color.
So let's do that.
I'm going to command-click on the color itself
and over here we dive into the variables of
that CSS file where the color was actually
defined.
My cursor goes right to the definition.
So now let's see.
I will probably want to make a change.
As I said, I'm really into indigo lately.
All right.
I'm going to hit command "S."
Now, one of the cool things that we have set
up is that if you have -- if you have a Sass
watch set up, so you're watching, you have
the -- the daemon sitting there waiting for
any changes to disk, we can actually use that
and then as new changes come into disk, we
can apply them.
So let me give this a shot.
I'm going to come back in here and make sure
that that setting is on.
Okay.
Autoreload CSS upon Sass save.
Come over and it looks like -- there we go.
Nice!
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: All right.
So I can make any changes to my Sass right
here inside the DevTools, change the color.
Maybe I'm -- I should go back to that green.
It's probably better than all these changes.
Just hit command "S" and due to workspaces,
as we saw before, my local development folder
is mapped to what's coming in over the wire
from local host, and so my changes are saved
back to disk and my watch picks it back up
and DevTools takes care of refreshing the
styles right inside the browser.
So this is really cool.
We have full traceability from any UI, from
selectors, properties, variables, back to
the mix-ins, the functions, the places in
the original sources where they were defined.
And the fact that this is powered by sourcemaps
-- you've heard about sourcemaps for JavaScript.
This is the exact same technology, only used
for CSS, and the DevTools team contributed
the sourcemap implementation into the core
Sass compiler to enable this functionality.
And we have the automatic reloaded style sheet
so as you edit inside the DevTools, you can
just keep going and see the changes as they
come in.
All right.
So these two features combined really kind
of change things.
It really means that DevTools can become my
editor.
I can style as I type, whether it's in CSS
or Sass.
These changes can be persisted to disk because
I'm mapping them right into my local folders.
My -- inside JavaScript I can re-evaluate
that -- re-evaluate it on the fly with live
edit and where I author is where I debug.
It's really powerful and we're excited about
what we can do now with this.
All right.
Now that we've covered kind of taking a look
at giving you more productive tools when authoring
sites, let's bring that to mobile.
All right.
So last year we talked about remote debugging
Chrome on Android.
Powerful stuff.
But it does require a bit of command line
hackery.
So who is a -- raise your hand if you've debugged
Chrome on Android.
[ Show of hands ]
>>Paul Irish: Cool.
Yeah.
That's great.
And raise your hand if you really enjoyed
dealing with ADB on the command line and memorizing
this -- that little guy at the bottom.
One second.
This is why you don't do hot spots on your
log screen.
All right.
Cool.
So this little guy.
Yeah.
Not the most fun.
So we thought that this could be better and
so this is our new and kind of experimental
UI for dealing with this.
So first thing is, beforehand you had to download
the Android SDK to make this work.
Now there's this little Chrome Extension.
See this guy?
We're just going to click on this guy and
start up ADB.
So actually the Chrome Extension itself ships
with ADB, which means I can just turn him
on there and he's going to turn on green once
ADB is running, and this means I don't need
to download the SDK whatsoever, just the 5-meg
Chrome Extension that takes care of this for
me.
All right.
Now, I'm going to plug in my phone.
Let's see.
And that's my password.
[ Laughter ]
>>Paul Irish: All right.
I'm about to plug it in and let me switch
back to the screen because it detects right
away that my device is in.
Awesome!
Good!
So now that that's in, let's check it out.
So I'm going to click again and go to devices,
view devices.
What this takes me to is the Chrome inspect
page, or about inspect.
You might have been here before if you've
had to download the background page for a
Chrome Extension or a shared worker.
It shows you all the targets that you could
debug.
And now, any targets that you have to debug
on a phone that's connected are going to show
up here.
So here's my Galaxy Nexus that I have connected
and we're seeing the page that I have open
right here.
So let's take a look.
All right.
Rock n' roll!
So this is the full DevTools.
Let me go over to Timeline and I'm just going
to record a quick Timeline as I scroll the
page.
And there we go.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: It's really powerful and we're
excited about having this -- the full functionality
of the DevTools available so conveniently.
And this is not just the full functionality
of the DevTools, but any Chrome Extensions
or DevTools extensions that you want.
Before, you didn't have available.
Now, say, for instance, you want to run Google
PageSpeed against your situation on the phone.
Right here -- my phone is actually still on
3G, and so I'm able to understand in real
network conditions what Google PageSpeed is
going to tell me.
But there is still a problem, so let's say
-- switch back here and I come over to this
file.
So before I was debugging, what, HTML5 Please
and it was coming over local host, and sometimes
I'm not able to have that available on my
phone.
Just doesn't come up.
So we thought we could probably fix this,
too.
So if I have this up here, I'm going to inspect
this target and go into the DevTools settings,
and you'll see here a new setting that's called
port forwarding.
And so now I can just add in I want to map
over port 9000, get that going, and we'll
come back over here and refresh and we're
good.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: So this is fantastic because
I can even use the functionality that I was
showing you before.
If I want to use workspaces and make a change
so this is the HTML of the page and I'm actually
just going to make a change to the source
markup, just hit command "S," command "R,"
and I come back over here and we just load
up the brand-new version.
Command "R" again, you know, for good luck.
[ Laughter ]
>>Paul Irish: And we're good.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: All right.
So I've just connected with -- with really
-- with a lot of ease to here.
I have workspaces, I have Sass debugging,
I have a lot of power, and I can focus my
development in improving this mobile experience,
which is really fantastic.
All right.
So no command line setup, see all your debug
targets in about inspect, great feature set
available, everything that's on desktop is
available for Chrome on Android, and port
forwarding to make this local development
feedback loop really fantastic and smooth.
All right.
Now, bringing this back up, I've covered authoring,
I've covered what we can do to make this experience
better on mobile.
Now, to dig into performance a little bit.
There's fantastic features and I'm going to
cover a few of the brand-new ones.
But the first thing when coming to performance
is that you've really got to focus on the
right priorities, finding your biggest bottlenecks
and focusing on those first.
And the Timeline is the best tool for this,
and I want to show this with a good example.
So here I have -- this is like an infographic
parallax site and what we do as we scroll
down, we've got this kind of orange circle
growth, we've got these white little guys
that are going to -- physics kind of going
out, we got this kind of section.
It's parallax.
It's really an attractive site.
And then down here, a little bit more changes.
I'm going to come back up to the top and now
let's take a look at this inside the Timeline.
I'm going to bring the DevTools down to the
bottom.
You can actually just drag it down.
All right.
I'm going to start a Timeline recording with
command "E," and just scroll through the page.
All right.
Now, what's really cool about what the Timeline
tells us is it basically tells us the narrative
of performance of this site.
As I scrolled through, a few things happened.
Up at the top, it was pretty quiet and it
was just the headline, and then here we got
into this green section.
What this was is a lot of draw calls.
Time is spent inside draw and painting, and
this is when all of these orange circles are
coming up and populating this screen.
Then we get into a lot of yellow, and what
this is is JavaScript execution, of course.
And this is coming in because of all the computation
required to make this functionality happen.
Then things are kind of pretty chill as we
go through this middle area.
We got -- we're mostly hitting our target
of 60fps, so we're staying within our frame
budgets, no big problems.
And then down towards the end where we have
this kind of effect, we're getting kind of
a cacophony of color.
Lots of different things happening at once.
Looks like a good amount of re-calc style,
layout, paint, and then also JavaScript all
happening at the same time.
But overall we get this really great view
of what the situations are, and first, I want
to call out that this is not really a DevTools
talk here at Chrome I/O. There's a lot of
other talks and some of them have already
happened, but if you want to dive into how
to figure out, you know, when you have a lot
of green, you're going to want to check out
these talks from the jankfree talk and the
device agnostic development talk.
Yellow, as luck would have it, is Follow the
Yellow Brick Road to JavaScript performance.
That just worked out really well.
The G -- if you're look at GCs and memory,
there was a great talk earlier about Gmail's
memory and performance and how the Chrome
DevTools help there.
Compositing there's actually great stuff,
and also layout, excellent stuff.
So dig into those talks as well so you can
find out how to use these tools in more detail.
But I want to show a brand-new feature and
let me show how it works.
All right.
So we're looking at this little section here
where we have the -- the -- all the little
balls that are kind of about to move around
once I start scrolling.
And I'm going to record a JavaScript profile
because, as we saw, a lot of yellow in that
section, and we want to know what's going
on.
Let's just try it.
I will hit command D once this gets going.
Come on.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
Command D to start and stop really fast.
And so what you get, yeah, is JavaScript profile.
And so what we're seeing here in aggregate
where my costs were spent.
And this is good.
But in some cases, it doesn't tell the whole
story.
You're interested in a picture that kind of
tells the story over time and you are just
seeing it at aggregate level.
But here we can turn on the flame chart down
at the bottom and we get to see a different
look.
This is over time where my time was spent
inside V8.
And in zoomout view, you get a sense of: Am
I doing the same sort of operations over time?
But I can also dive in a little bit closer
and understand what's going on.
>>> Wow.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: So I want to point out a little
bit on how to read this.
Callstack is the Y axis.
So height doesn't matter too much.
What you are looking for is wide bars that
are taking up time.
In this case, it looks like -- let's see,
this little flame over here, we have a little
bit of a pub sub.
It is not too heavy.
But it looks like most of our ticks are inside
of d3, inside of this quadtreeview call and
then a lot of insertchilds construct right
here.
We are able to get a good visual view of where
our costs are, and then we can dive in and
make some optimizations later.
All right.
We also have a new experiment for profiling
Canvas, and I want to show you how this works.
So this is just a WebGL experiment, and we
are going to open up the profiling panel.
And we are going to select "capture canvas
frame."
Now, it just captured one frame of the canvas.
And it is going to dig into all the draw calls.
Here we'll listen to every single draw call
that's happened to that canvas and we can
just go down, down, down, apply them one by
one, and see how they affect and how this
frame is built up over time.
And then we can open up one of those draw
calls and see all the functions that contributed
to that specific draw.
And if we want, we can click over to the sources
panel to see the source of each of those functions.
Now, this is just a platform.
We have great recording to be able to instrument
record and replay canvas.
This is both 2D Canvas and WebGL.
Now, what really happens next is up to you.
There is -- we could add a lot of features
to this but we are interested in your feedback
to hear what would be most useful to make
this great and improve the performance of
your apps.
All right.
So five more key performance features.
I don't have too much time, but I want to
show them off pretty quick.
All right.
Continuous repainting mode.
Fantastic if you are seeing a lot of green
in your timeline view.
You have a lot of paint costs and you want
to find out why.
Turn on continuous repaint mode.
This is going to tell the browser to paint,
paint, paint.
And then you are able to turn off DOM, turn
off different styles, see what is affecting
your paints the most.
In some cases, it is a little hard to see.
Maybe box shadow and border reduce are on.
Maybe they are not too additive.
It is a little tricky.
This will give you a lot of insight.
The fps meter has been in there for a while,
but it has been getting a lot of upgrades.
You are able to see how fast you are throwing
frames to the graphics context.
You will get a histogram view over here, a
min and max.
And the GPU memory.
This is really important on mobile where you
only have a set amount of GPU memory.
If you are constantly evicting things out
of the GPU memory, it might be slowing down
how fast the user is actually seeing things.
And this going to give you a lot of insight.
Show paint, rects and layer borders, these
are settings inside the DevTools.
Great for understanding if you are getting
a lot of paints, what is the size and shape
of these paints.
Maybe it is the entire screen is repainted
-- repainting every time you scroll.
We want to understand that and find out why.
In this screen shot, we can see that our a
little dataset div just got repainted, and
we got a composite layer border around this
side.
This is actually the scroll bar, which the
browser is now compositing on top of the page
content.
Object allocation tracking is brand-new.
This is basically taking continuous heap snapshots
over time.
And you are able to identify where objects
are being created and identify the retain
path.
Great if you are digging into the memory performance
of your app.
Layout thrashing is a big problem with DOM
-- with the Web application's DOM performance.
So a lot of times, you will be touching the
DOM.
It will cause layout thrashing or reflows.
And here we're able to not only see a few
things.
So in timeline, you are going to see a little
icon if DevTools detects this is a forced
synchronous layout.
It is going to tell you it might be a possible
performance bottleneck.
You are doing more layouts than you have to.
The user is not even seeing the work you're
forcing.
Then it will tell you the call stacks, why
exactly the layout was forced, and why it
was invalidated.
You can dig into the sources right there and
see the actual call that forced it.
Now this is brand-new stuff.
Identify what nodes need layout, how many
there are, what the total tree size that's
getting reflowed is, and where the document
root is.
Sometimes -- sometimes the entire document
is being laid out again.
Other times it is just a partial layout.
All right.
So a lot of stuff here.
And you can try it out today.
We have just been working -- put in a lot
of work on the DevTools documentation.
So not even -- there is a lot more I didn't
even show, and we have great docs to back
it up.
I encourage you to check those out.
And everything I showed today, all these features,
are available in Chrome Canary now.
So you can go, check them out, give them a
shot, give us your feedback.
Thank you guys very much.
[ Applause ]
And we have some time for questions.
So I'm going to invite Pavel up on stage with
me.
And if you have any questions, I encourage
you to line up at the mics.
Sir?
>>> Hello.
I was just wondering how much of this is available
if you use GWIT to develop the Web site?
>>Paul Irish: GWIT?
GWIT?
>>> Google Web toolkit.
>>Pavel Feldman: It depends on whether you
are using Sourcemaps for GWIT.
If you are using Sourcemaps, you have got
all the debugging capabilities.
Sourcemaps and Workspace are working well
together.
So you get pretty much all of it.
>>> So it is integrated as the Sass you showed?
>>Pavel Feldman: Yeah.
So you will need to take care of generating
JavaScript off your Java.
And you might need to add a bit of extra to
reload it so that it was reloaded automatically.
But you can edit Java.
You can save it to disk.
Sourcemaps will be catching up.
You can debug using Workspace and Sass in
the time.
>>> Cool, thank you.
>>> Hi, I'm (saying name) from LinkedIn Mobile.
So Chrome DevTools are amazing.
They're awesome.
But what would be even more awesome, right,
is if we could use all these, the heap profile,
the performance profile in Node.
And there is a few projects, Node Inspector,
Webkit Agent, Node Agent, that have been doing
a pretty good job but the problem is that
they can't keep up with the development speed
of the Chrome DevTool team and the V8 team.
And I'm curious if there are any plans to
support no debugging memory management in
Node?
>>Paul Irish: So node -- I know Node Agent
-- Node Inspector, of course, is not as maintained
as it was before.
>>> It's dead.
Officially dead.
>>Paul Irish: Node Agent is picking up where
it left off.
Great profiling capabilities.
In fact, I was just talking to the author
of it, like, three days ago about getting
flame chart support inside there.
Be trivial for him to add.
Those are all done over the V8 protocol.
So it's not too hard to bring in the front
end which is completely open source, just
the Web app, and hook up to the V8 protocol
and bring in those features.
So --
>>> At the same time, it's hard, right, because
there is no support for breakpoints.
There is no support for stepping through code
into Webkit Agent.
So I'm just curious if is any desire for the
Chrome team to actually enable remote V8 debugging.
>>Pavel Feldman: So we are not using the old
V8 protocol for debugging in Chrome DevTools
at the moment.
We are based on the Webkit or now Chrome remote
debugging protocol.
So it requires some native code supported
in Node and exposing particular features including
support of the transport over the WebSockets
for the whole story to work.
So it is just an effort.
We are happy to assist there or work with
Node on making it greater, better, and faster.
But it just requires some work.
>>> Excellent.
Thank you.
>>> Hi.
I heard there were some experiments at integrating
Code Mirror and ACE into the syntax highlighting.
Is there any ETA where you are headed with
any of that?
>>Pavel Feldman: Sure.
Code Mirror, you can enable it today in settings
and you will be using it is as your default
editor.
We are still figuring out the editor story.
We are unhappy with anything we see because
we need to -- we are kind of a unique situation
where you need to be able to debug obfuscated
Gmail where lines are tens of thousands of
characters.
At the same time, you want to wrap it, native
feedback and feel for the editing.
So we are still unhappy with everything we
have.
We are working on the hybrid approach that
would address all of these and make it the
best editor.
>>> Cool.
Thank you.
>>> Hi there.
Great stuff.
The Chrome extension that you showed off,
I don't see it on the DevTools site.
Is it out or is it?
Is it just in your Github repo?
Where is that?
The Android thing that kicks ass.
Like, how do we download it?
>>Pavel Feldman: It is in my github repo.
>>Paul Irish: This is how I always get to
it.
>>Pavel Feldman: A little disclaimer.
The way it works, it bundles ADB.
It bundles ADB and it works only for Mac only
at this moment.
It may be easy to make it work on Linux, not
as easy to make it work on Windows because
of the USB drivers.
We are working hard to resolve that and make
it useful everywhere and convenient to everybody.
But it's currently in the preview mode.
That's why you don't see it on our Web page.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> The editor features you have shown will
make it much more convenient to use a device
like a Chromebook Pixel to do real Web development.
I'm wondering if the Workspace features that
you showed have filesystem access?
So if you have user local mydev files running
on your machine, will you be able to edit
those from the Chrome DevTools on the Chromebook?
>>Pavel Feldman: Under the hood, it is the
filesystem API that's mapping things directly
to your filesystem.
On any device that has filesystem, Workspace
will work, including Chrome OS where you can
map it to your downloads folder or your drive.
We are generally unhappy with the -- our development
story on Chrome as yet, and we are working
on it because important things such as version
control integration are missing.
So we want a complete, full-fledged story
there.
We are just not there yet.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Hello.
So two -- first one quick question.
So you were trying when you edited a file
in your editor in Sublime, it will it load
automatically in DevTools and I guess not
just in the DevTools but, like, in the pages,
right?
The question is -- second question is more
about how far are you -- do you think you
will take DevTools in terms of editing?
Like, for example, I work on backbone applications
where it would be great if I could jump to
definition of the method from one class to
its superclass and kind of things.
>>Pavel Feldman: Okay.
ID future center refactorings, we are editing
because you want it.
And we started with the debugging.
We considered ourselves as a debugging instrumenting
platform.
But we can see that there is so much failure
that can be added through by adding basic
editing capabilities that we are on this route
now.
And the time will show how far we would like
to go there.
But things like code completion are definitely
in our plans.
>>Paul Irish: One of the other things -- Chrome
DevTools actually uses -- you have heard of
the uglify minifier.
When it was working on the 2.0 with Sourcemaps
support, we helped their crown funding contribution
for that.
Similarly, we used Code Mirror.
Code Mirror is available, and the author behind
Code Mirror has been working on a new kind
of insight for static analysis of JavaScript
called TURN.
And we contributed also to that, and we are
watching that project very closely.
Sir, in the back?
>>> The things that you showed us with OS
are awesome.
Do you have any plans to support other frameworks
such as layers or stylus?
>>Paul Irish: So I should have pointed out
that what I showed was abstracted style support.
It's all based -- as I mentioned, it is all
based off of Sourcemaps.
And so nothing in our implementation is specific
to Sass.
It is just to specific to Sourcemap support.
So if Sourcemaps are supported inside the
compiler for either layers or stylus, then
DevTools will start working with them today.
>>> Thank you.
>>Paul Irish: All right.
Thanks, everyone.
Appreciate it.
[ Applause ]